what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so as much as I love talking about
movies we got a little carried away like
the infinity war trailer came out that
was like movie stuff let's talk about
movie stuff and I got I got really
really excited for a like for like four
days it was just cranking out movie
stuff but we are how much explained so
we explained how excited we make sense
of it all and in this video we are going
to be continuing our run on Hickman's
Avengers and new Avengers now again it
been a little while since we done the
first video right I mean we went back we
were like okay look hated the old
stories way we did him like we're going
back and remastering it all in my
current style but we did that one a
while ago and so to kind of refresh for
people who never really saw that first
when you'll find it down in the
description so you can get like the full
effect you'll find that Marvel
chronology playlist but the whole idea
with that story is that again remember
when Jonathan Hickman writes stories
he's very cloak-and-dagger in terms of
how he does things in the sense that he
starts from the end and works his way
back to the beginning and so it's
basically like this huge grandiose thing
that happens at the conclusion of the
story and everything makes sense but in
the beginning it's little tidbits here
little tidbits there and a little clue
there and a little clue there and that's
it it's kind of up to us to sort of
figure things out so what we do is we
pick up in the Necropolis with Tony
Stark and with black panther and those
guys and the reason why is because with
this coming immediately after the first
video what we saw in that was that there
was basically just some being called a
gardener and we didn't really know a
whole lot about him but this was a guy
who basically began to terraform Mars
basically and his goal was to actually
speed up the evolution of humanity on
earth but the idea having been I've been
initiated that the gardener had tried to
create life of course the Avengers more
or less defeated him but one of the new
beings that have been created was just
this young black kid and so the
immediate aftermath of all this is
basically what was going on with the
character of Black Swan this woman that
just showed up from a different earth
that was basically showing up you know
in the in the atmosphere of the main
Marvel Universe you know why did she
destroy that planet what in the world is
going on of course again at the moment
she's being held prisoner but the whole
idea was to basically bring in this
concept of the incursions that there is
basically a colliding of universes going
on when an earth shows up in the
atmosphere of you know the the main
Marvel Universe there's 8 hours between
those Earth's crashing into each other
if they both had both universes get
destroyed if one earth
destroyed the universes just passed
through each other and that's it the
question is what was she using to
destroy these worlds how was she blowing
up this alternate earth and so what we
end up having is this sort of discussion
between Reed and Black Panther and Tony
Stark that she was effectively using an
antimatter bomb and it's kind of funny
because Tony Stark makes this comment
there's a little bit of irony and using
an antimatter bomb to destroy a world
we've talked about things like the
negative zone which is basically a sort
of alternate dimension that's composed
of antimatter and what we basically said
is that if antimatter hits positive
matter they'll basically cancel each
other out and so what that means is it
would be like two of your fists hitting
each other and just obliterating
everything and that's the whole idea of
Black Swan if you want to destroy
positive matter absolutely and
definitively use antimatter the whole
idea is to also try to find ways to stop
these incursions from happening remember
we talked in the last video that the
first response of the illuminati of this
basically this group that we're reading
about right now their first response was
to use the Infinity Gauntlet
historically speaking the Infinity
Gauntlet is the most powerful artifact
that any of these characters have used
now again there is the heart of the
universe but the Marvel brass the
various top editors you know Tom
Brevoort so on and so forth they've all
come out and said that story's not in
continuity so it's not really an
arguable point but in this instance the
Infinity Gauntlet has been the most
powerful artifact that's ever existed
the fact that the Infinity stones were
destroyed when they were trying to stop
an encouragement means that now it's a
mad dash to try to keep it from
happening and so while all these various
individuals have began putting together
these different plans and so on and so
forth Tony Stark's idea is to actually
form a Dyson Sphere I'm by no means a
scientist but to my understanding a
dices a Dyson Sphere is a theoretical
concept but a Dyson Sphere is basically
a giant spherical structure this
essentially builds around a star and
it's designed to harness the power that
star puts out solar flares different
things like that and then use that for
whatever it is that you know its purpose
serves in this instance and is actually
sheer genius on behalf of Tony Stark is
trying to push a universe back with the
Infinity Gauntlet didn't work then
perhaps they can just sort of obliterate
these planets without actually having to
travel to them that's the funny thing
with a bomb that that Black Swan has she
has to jump from one world
and to the other presumably when another
incursion happens if she's free she
would leave the earth in the main Marvel
Universe jumped to whatever alternate
earth is there and then blow up the
earth in the main Marvel Universe that
would be her answer to try to keep the
incursions from happening now the whole
response of Tony Stark is a we're just
gonna beat her to the punch
anytime another alternate Earth's shows
up we're going to destroy it but they
don't necessarily have the resources to
continually develop all these antimatter
bombs or at least not in the time they
have allotted because they don't know
when the next incursion is going to
happen and so the response of Tony Stark
is we need a long game and so the whole
point of this Dyson Sphere is to
basically use a Dyson Sphere to emit a
beam of energy much like a Death Star to
destroy an earth whenever it shows up
but the long game is to have this Dyson
Sphere 100% completed so that when
another incursion happens they can
literally push the whole thing away but
it's cool because the name that Reed
Richards gives this is Saul's hammer
this is why I say all the Jonathan
Hickman stories are completely and
totally cohesive and Jonathan Hickman's
run on the Fantastic Four when the mad
Celestials from another universe invaded
the main Marvel Universe with the
intention of conquering this entire
reality Reed Richards developed a
massive gun more or less that can be
used to blast the Celestials and blow
them to pieces and it was called Saul's
anvil the other half of this is remember
the Illuminati is composed of Reed
Richards and Black Panther you know it
was all these different characters that
are there but you also have Doctor
Strange
now Doctor Strange his specialty is the
mystic arts he's got nothing to offer
when it comes to dyson sphere's and
technology and so on and so forth and so
his idea is to basically use his various
magics to try to find a way to end the
incursions the problem with this and
with Doctor Strange is he's delving into
black magic that if invoked and if
misused can lead to the arrival of
beings like Dormammu nightmare all these
different you know wildly powerful
demonic entities that could easily lay
waste up all the Earth's superheroes so
again Doctor Strange is walking a very
tight rope here and so ultimately what
they end up having is another incursion
that takes place and so what is up going
on is there's basically this incursion
that takes place in Ellis Island in New
York so everyone around there sees this
earth and so when the Illuminati take
off and they basically run over to Ellis
Island and their immediate response is
to jump to that earth and to figure out
what's going on once they arrive they
say okay we have to figure out what the
scenario is
once they basically get there we end up
finding that galactus from this
alternate reality is on this alternate
earth building a mega structure now
remember collages with all the other
superheroes that existed here Hinkley
just kind of leave it to us to figure
out what's going on they know about the
incursions and that's huge because the
response of Galactus is Harold at the
time Terrax the enlightened basically
says we know about the incursions we're
aware these earths are gonna crash into
each other we're taking care of this one
your earth will be safe but we won't be
there forever but what it means is that
the Illuminati learning about the
incursions black swans showing up
destroying the earth it's not a small
thing and that's what we're gonna find
out as we go through this that there are
thousands of people who are out there
there are all these hundreds and dozens
and thousands of iterations of the main
Marvel characters in different universes
who all know about the incursions and
are all trying to stop it eventually
it'll come down to three main groups the
Illuminati is one of them we're not
going to go over the other ones because
I don't want to spoil anything what we
end up finding out is that by extension
of the actions of Galactus this is a
multiversal effort to stop the
incursions from happening everybody
realizes the end of the multiverse is at
hand
if the incursions are allowed to
continue going on and so that's kind of
the funny thing is because one of the
other things that Eric's the enlightened
says is that there have been people who
have been fleeing from universes
traveling to other universes there are
some people that reside in this universe
who came from other universes and there
were whispers and there were rumors
about a collapse of the multiverse
incursions happening Earth's crashing
into each other all these you know
scenarios that have been unfolding all
these things that have been going on
where people are just fleeing just
trying to get out as best they can
before their universe comes to an end
Herod seizes this idea they know a lot
more than the earth superheroes do and
we'd be expected to believe that's true
it's cool it is pretty intriguing it's
pretty interesting in terms of what's
been going on and how all this has been
happening again a lot of that's not
really given to us explicitly but Reed
Richards basically shows up with the
intention of using the ultimate
nullifier as an attempt to destroy
Galactus in order to try to save this
world and try to find a way to
simultaneously stop the incursions well
the funny thing about Terra's response
is you can't if you genuinely believe
you can keep these incursions from
happening and save both earths
then you have no clue
what's going on and so my advice is to
leave this earth get out of this reality
go back to your home universe and just
destroy whatever Earth's and curse on
yours that's the response they've been
getting time and time again from Black
Swan has always been you can't stop the
quote unquote real of destruction you
cannot stop the incursions from
happening but the nature of the
Illuminati is there has to be a way to
stop this there has to be some
scientific answer to how to keep the
incursions from happening in the face of
guaranteed doom their answer is but
there has to be a way for us to win the
fight ultimately breaks out which we
interact the enlightened and in the
Illuminati and before we find out what
happens this story basically ends but
what it does from here is it actually
picks up with a young girl with some guy
that has some sort of an artifact and
basically ends up dying in some major
conflict and that's really about it but
the cool thing is that the artifact
Moore's itself into glasses are into
goggles that this girl in turn puts on
in this instance this story focuses on a
young girl named Izzy and is he's
basically just this girl that lives on a
farm in Iowa she's got a pretty mundane
life is he going out taking these
goggles with her looking into his
telescope exploring space to a degree it
gives us a couple things about her
character the first is that she much
like a lot of people who were raised in
small towns who look for bigger and
better things
dream of a better life what she puts
these goggles on suddenly she's told
that she's being given the designation
of smasher and she's basically being
sent to the planet of Chandalar this is
a big deal because Chandalar is home for
the Shiar empire and the imperial guard
what we end up finding out is there's
actually a Stargate that orbits earth
this Stargate no one knows about is a
stealth Stargate and it's kind of cool
because what it does is it hits at this
idea that the Shiar Empire is so
technologically advanced but they can
basically throw in a universal
transportation device and earth doesn't
know about it but this girl showing up
here is intriguing because basically she
learns that she's being brought in to be
one of the recruits for the Imperial
garden and we'll talk about them here in
a second but before we do what we end up
doing here is switching over to Avengers
tower now remember because of the fact
of the stories of Jonathan Hickman's run
is split between Avengers and New
Avengers New Avengers is designed to
tell the story of the Illuminati
Avengers is their front face it's the
face they put on for the rest of the
world and that's why you'll see them in
both stories in this instance you have
Tony Stark and everybody is basically
trying to figure out who this
young kid is that was created during the
events of the Avengers world storyline
he basically says his name is black veil
or at least that's the indication that's
given because what he's doing is he's
speaking builder machine code might as
well be Greek for you know all the good
it does and these guys trying to figure
it out the best they can do is try to
decipher it by a combination of just
guessing their intelligence and then
whatever little assistance they can get
so they come to the conclusion that this
kid's name is basically black veil
that's the name that he's calling
himself the other half of this is that
the Avengers are starting to get an SOS
from some various forces that are going
on their various conflict is taking
place basically out in the Galactic rim
of the Shiar empire now remember in
Marvel Comics the Shiar Empire is an
amalgamation of all these races that
swear loyalty to the Magister or the
magistrate's whoever it is it's running
it at the time at this moment right now
it's a gladiator the leader of the
Imperial Guard and the whole idea behind
this is that with the Shiar empire
governing governing it's its empire very
very jealously they never really allow
anybody in unless they're invited or
unless they're conquered but what's
going on here is some race some alien
society has basically begun infringing
on the Galactic rim of the Shiar empires
territory and so what is up happening is
we actually have falcon along with a
handful of avengers who respond to these
sort of SOS a--'s and begin showing up
and you know and basically getting
involved in everything at the same time
is also the character of Izzy who jumps
into the conflict as well this is
designed to give us this sort of
universal calamity or at least this
small skirmish through the eyes of a new
person this is all new to her and in her
first really her first run out in terms
of becoming an actual superhero fighting
alongside these she our soldiers she's
suddenly thrown out into the middle of
everything but notice how she handles it
she takes it in stride and that's
designed to basically reiterate the fact
that Izzy's ability to function as the
character of Smasher and basically as a
hero goes beyond the simple powers that
she has but she has a strong character
about her with the Avengers showing up
and everything The Incredible Hulk
emerging we jump back to the first time
that she first flew when she first saw
the planet of Chandalar you know and
what we end up finding out is that when
she first put on those goggles about a
month ago non her first exploration into
space and the time that she returned
back home so again she basically makes
this comment about how easy it is to get
lost in space the time
is faster than you would expect it will
and so when she gets back a couple of
things go on the first is that she
basically has a conversation of sorts
with her father and she's basically told
look your granddad sick which is kind of
disappointing because the two of them
were so close but it's also her granddad
basically giving her this piece of paper
that basically says I got this from a
friend of mine when I was younger his
statement was basically if you ever need
anything give me a call now when we had
talked about the idea that Jonathan
Hickman would borrow heavily from
established comics all throughout
Marvel's history this is a perfect
example this granddad this old man is
not a random person he's actually a guy
by the name of Dan King and I didn't
even think about this until I saw this
note that Steve Rogers left him um now
we got to pull out the memory bank so we
got to pull out some some old school
stuff in order to in order to do this
but Dan Caine was actually a guy named
captain terror and back in the 1940s
when Captain America first popped up in
Marvel Comics the whole idea was that
all comic books were basically part of
the total war effort during World War
Two in the sense that almost every facet
of American society was geared towards
propelling this belief that America was
right I mean whether it was because
people were contributing in the war
effort in terms of neo making guns and
tanks and so on and so forth or whether
it was propaganda like comic books well
Captain America Superman Batman Wonder
Woman
you know while those stand out is some
of the most iconic characters to come
out of World War two there were other
smaller characters to you and in fact
there was a line of comics called USA
comics and the star of that or at least
one of the stars of that was Captain
Terror Dan Caine but he also had a hand
event and some of the Captain America
efforts what Jonathan Hickman is doing
here is grabbing all that history and
reeling it in and basically saying
Captain America knows who Dan Caine is
he fought alongside him during World War
two and that's what he means when he
tells his daughter you're part of a
lineage you're part of a history that
you never knew about superhero epics run
in our blood it's part of who we are and
he basically teaches her the most
important lesson of what it means to be
a superhero that being a superhero
basically means that you inspire other
people to believe that they can do great
things and so it's beautifully done and
it's this incredible encounter because
what ends up happening is we actually
have Gladiator of the Shiar Empire the
Magister who shows up with the Imperial
Guard basically the most elite fighting
force in the universe who essentially
eliminate you know all these different
alien threats and
the actions of smasher and basically
being able to hold the line as part of
the Shiar military force she's given an
honorary position and made part of the
Imperial Guard the first human to
achieve that so it's cool and so in
response to this what we do is we pick
up with the last little tidbit of the
story back on Chandalar and is basically
the Shiar empire more or less torturing
this guy for information doing whatever
it is they have to do to get information
out of him on why they were encroaching
on the territory of the Shiar and where
you know gladiator believed it was an
attempt at an invasion
what Oracle their local telepath does is
she says it's nothing like that
instead it's worse than what we thought
it was they weren't looking to invade us
they were fleeing this just happened to
be what we caught them but the only
reason why they were here was because
something was hunting them something
drove them from their own home territory
their own galaxy or whatever it was and
it brought them here and we destroyed
them while they were in the midst of
trying to get to safety but without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like I love Jonathan
Hickman's run on Avengers the New
Avengers and it only gets better it only
gets so much better it gets crazy
oh dude when we get to the point where
it's like The Last Stand of Hyperion and
Thor they're just one of the coolest
moments in the whole store is is one of
the best things that happens I mean it
gets dude it gets absolutely bonkers
it's pretty wild but anyway guys we're
gonna bring this to an end and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]